- Scarlett Johansson is suing Disney
over the release of the
movie "Black Widow."
ScarJo claims that she was entitled
to a percentage of the
box office receipts.
But here's the thing:
Disney released the movie "Black Widow"
on their streaming platform, Disney Plus,
at the same time that they
released the movie in theaters.
The movie made $60 million
on the streaming service,
but only $20 million in theaters.
Johansson is claiming that
the term in the contract,
"Theatrical release," means an
exclusive theatrical release,
meaning only in theaters for
a specific period of time
and not simultaneously
on any other platform.
Disney, I'm sure, is going
to claim that, in fact,
the term theatrical release means
that they just have to
release the movie in theaters,
and that, so long as they do
so, they can also release it
on their streaming
platform at the same time
and they have upheld the contract.
We don't have the specific
contract in front of us,
but it's pretty suspicious
that the plaintiff, Johansson,
has not included that language,
or at least is only referring
to the term theatrical release
without any kind of exclusivity
clause attached to it.
So, she may have a very uphill battle
in this particular lawsuit,
but we will see them in court.